hey everyone welcome back to the games
foot stage here at e3 2017 joining Dave
and myself is Clint coming to talk to us
about crackdown 3 yes how was your show
going so far it's been great yeah I mean
let's Terry Crews yes ok how long have
you been sat on that for a while yeah we
want to know the e3 for us this year was
all about revealing our campaign Express
yeah nobody had seen campaign yet we
talked a lot about destruction and our
cloud compute and that's part of our
competitive multiplayer experience
absolutely part of crackdown 3 no mates
in campaign yet oh so we wanted to come
and and show campaign for the first time
and show off the partnership with Terry
Crews and it's it's been awesome getting
to see people play the game for the
first time I've heard rumors that Cruz
himself is actually around somewhere and
she ate those my oh I have heard similar
rumors that he may be at some point I
honestly don't know if it's now I'm
leaving yeah just this interview is done
you're out yeah that's what I'm in I
would not be offended if you swapped me
out I'm not gonna lie you say I'll go
how did the whole partnership with Terry
come about um you know Cherry's a huge
gamer loves games it I did enjoy seeing
him play back was a battlefront last
year a battlefield won a field one he's
recently built his own pcs yeah yeah
yeah so it was such a perfect
partnership and some conversations you
know I think he really wanted to be in
the game and so you know now not only is
he character in the game he's commander
Jackson here he's actually playable and
you can play as Terry Crews both in
campaign and in competitive multiplayer
incredible but does um so you have you
have Terry Crews are they gonna be other
celebrities are you gonna be taken like
right now I'm for full front right now
we're only talking about Terry Crews
high but just it's been all so at the
funny story about him we were shooting
that opening and he's running around and
he's still being Terry Crews
he would flex he would break the suit
like in higher panels of it would flip
up and somebody to run out and glue him
back down and put him back together and
then he would go back to doing his thing
and that gun he's carrying we actually
built me ya know it's an actual prop and
the first saw I really
gun is enormous and then he put it in
his hand you like that the red sauce um
alright so let's talk crackdown 3 so
it's been a while since you guys done
now you guys announced and you went
quiet for a bit
little resurgence and now you're back in
full force ready to release later this
year yes
November 7th wow so what's it like kind
of finally having it out there like in
more than just like one trailer actually
having people get their hands in the
game it's it's been incredible you know
what we have on the show floor is what
we call our skills for kills challenge
it's essentially a sandbox who put our
craziest weapons up on the rooftops and
people are going around and taking out
different parts of the gangs business
and and collecting orbs and it's it's
just this challenge to get the highest
score and and for us it's just been so
exciting to watch people play it and
people come around you know these
hardcore crackdown fans it's back and it
feels like crackdown but it feels like
this this way you pushed it forward we
had a double jump and an airburst and so
you have some more controls and you have
some crazy weapons we have the
singularity weapon that creates black
holes but because crackdown such a
physical game right where you can you
know smash a light pole and then pick it
up and use it as a javelin everything in
the world is physical so when you create
that black hole it sucks in enemies it
sucks in props and cars and everything
else and then sends them flying it
chairs monorail carriages off the
monorail line and so people are having a
lot of fun just dealing with all of our
crazy weapons a lot of people have said
the people have had some hands-on
they've compared it it's more like
crackdown 1 than it is to crack down to
is that was that a conscious thing
returning to your roots after the kind
of departure when you went to crackdown
to the whole mutants thing absolutely
you know we we wanted to take it back to
its roots you know we wanted to create
this all new criminal empire so it's an
all new city and that city is completely
controlled by criminal empire that calls
itself Terra Nova city is twice as large
as the one in the original and the
tallest building in the original was the
agency tower the tallest building and
the new one is the kingpin tower and it
is twice the height actually Tower so
not only we got in a much larger
footprint we have just insane amounts of
verticality but for us did that that
gang that criminal empire was such a
part of it in a game like this where the
entire city is open to you from the
beginning
where
there's no you know you failed because
you left the mission area this is a game
where like the gate the mission is to
dismantle the organization you just
mental in any way you can and players
use the crazy tools we give them in this
exponential power curve and I'm super
excited to see how players do it well
with it being called crackdown 3 is
there a necessity for players to have
played 1 and 2 or can you just go in
fresh and just be exposed to the
craziness from the get-go there you do
not need to play the originals I I love
the original so I would never tell
anybody they shouldn't but but you
absolutely don't need to this is it's
its own narrative it takes place more
than 10 years after the events of the
second one
there'll be some familiar voices for
fans of the original such as the voice
of the agency but you don't need to have
played the originals to understand
what's happening does the freedom that
you're creating with the open world also
translate to the campaign a lot of
people have been saying that it's
possible to just go to the head kingpin
and fight him rather than chip away as
lieutenants that is so crackdowns a game
where really we give the player their
tools and then we unleash them into this
giant sandbox and we see the choices
they make and we want to make sure that
the game reacted to those choices so the
beginning of the game the entire city is
open you can go right after the kingpin
if you want it's gonna be incredibly
hard you're gonna be under levelled I'm
sure somebody will figure it out and in
you know the world of games probably oh
somebody figures it out with it they won
yeah exactly
but that's that's what's exciting for us
you know this this is a game where it's
it's different for every player and a
big part of that's the system we call
gangs bite back so every one of our
crime bosses has something in the world
that they care about a part of the
organization that they run as a player
you want to figure out what that is and
attack it and that pisses them off and
as you piss them off they add defenses
to their areas and then eventually
they'll start to retaliate they'll send
people after you that can happen
anywhere in the world so you'll have
fights in an area that I didn't fight
anybody and that's just because that's
where you were when that retaliation was
triggered you go through enough of that
you can finally pull those bosses into
play and they'll come after you
personally so those bosses are also
those boss battles are also completely
dynamic
yeah all of that gives players where
it's this feeling of the way that I
dismantled terranova was completely
different than the way somebody else did
and every playthrough feels different
I mean speak I mean you mentioned the
word dismantle let's talk about your
destruction so that was really like the
first thing that was shown off what the
game was that ever it was powered by the
cloud and it was like the first time
really we'd seen that how has that
technology evolved since that first
showing because it wasn't really a big
part of this year's press conference
right it was it was a single-player but
like so well how how is it I was going
to work so the cloud compute gives us
these hundred percent destructible
environments where you're tearing down
buildings and creating your own paths
through maps and it gives players just
totaled agency over the map and so like
I said that's that's all about our
competitive multiplayer experience and
people will definitely be learning more
about that soon the figure originally
was it made it 20 times more powerful
than Xbox one right is that still the
figure as it changed with the Xbox one X
have you been able to refine and make it
even more powerful still the kind of
competition computational requirements
of that that mode and the are
competitive multiplayer experience
that's nothing's changed that is the
exact same so it's you know Xbox one X
you'll get it in 4k and of course our
explosions and everything else they look
amazing in 4k but we we're still going
to use the cloud to power our
competitive multiplayer experience so
it's just for the cloud confusion is
just for competitive multiplayer not
going to transfer to the single player
correct so in the campaign mode you have
online which you can play in four player
co-op and then you have offline that you
can play single-player and so in
campaign you save the city and
competitive multiplayer you wreck it
have you designed an eco multiplayer
game modes around destruction like the
fastest group to destroy a city wins
sort of thing is that something you're
thinking about to really play upon those
destruction mechanics you bill I mean
destruction is such a game-changing
mechanic it changes the way you think
about everything from having to how you
design levels and everything so I'm
super excited to to talk more about that
kind of stuff but like I said it 83 this
year
we're all about campaign and we're gonna
talk more about the competitive
multiplayer soon all right so you said
the whole city's open to you as soon as
like as soon as you drop into the game
yes how is that gonna work with like
onboarding like tutorials or is it just
basically for the player who like yeah
you go out there you figure it out
yourself
so I mean much like the originals you
have the voice of the agency in your ear
and this is the you know one of the
characters that really helps you
understand you know what's going on and
you are and what you should be doing in
the world but because it's this giant
sandbox players we never completely
limit the player we never block off
parts of the city you don't fail because
you left the mission area and so we give
you the entire city but certainly we're
gonna help players kind of figure out
how to play the game and we want players
obviously have success and we want them
climbing up and collecting orbs and
getting these crazy weapons and leveling
up their skills for kills and it's a
wheeled we'll have plenty of stuff to
get people there you mentioned orbs
that's obviously a very classic
crackdown staple is it is it this the
same as the original crackdown or have
you evolved the orb system you have
great system into something a little
different this time
so the kills four kills system we really
took again kind of taking it back to its
roots
we took that original system but we
wanted to add some stuff to it so it
still has that crazy exponential curve
where the beginning of the game you know
you're throwing rocks or trash cans
you know but you know level up a couple
of times and suddenly you're throwing
giant fuel trucks and you know begin the
game you're running around you feel
really fast but you level up your
agility a couple times and suddenly
you're jumping over entire buildings and
so that that's still it's such a part of
the DNA the franchise I mean crackdown
was always such a vertical platformer
but now what we wanted to add with some
some new abilities you unlock as you
progress so we've added a double jump
we've added an air burst we've we've you
know added the ability be able to pick
up objects from a distance so that you
could do everything on the run
you never really have to stop so you can
jump through the air and target a card
sub target the gas cap blow up the car
turn pulling on a prop off a rooftop
throw and hit somebody with it all
before you hit the ground and the idea
is again just give player all these
crazy options and then see how they play
with all of these sort of these
variables right through play testing you
guys must have come up against some like
I didn't know it could do that
always but that's for me and that's just
personally these are the kinds of games
I love to make it I like games where you
know players can create their own
experiences in many ways and I think
then you multiply that by four players
and co-op you multiply that by dynamic
boss battles that can happen anywhere so
the three of us could be playing
together in three different parts of the
city pissing off three different gang
bosses at the same time triggering
retaliations pulling bosses into play
and all be happening in the same world
and that that for me it's so interesting
to see a game that kind of allows the
player to make those kinds of second to
second choices how to want to play this
game and that it can react to them I've
been reading a lot about the
retaliations retaliation system it
sounds like there's a lot of emerging
gameplay there you can get a retaliation
flee to another area all that chaos
creates another retaliation how chaotic
can it get is it can you get like a
whole city on your back or something it
can be incredibly chaotic so will you
know we'll have some ways for players to
feel like if they need to cool it down
they can cool it down but at the end of
the day I mean this is a game that's
bombastic it's crazy over-the-top and so
we we want to make sure that we can
crank that up and we've always talked
about crackdown as being the the opie
game and it's a game where you have a
black hole gun like I have another one
called the micro missile launcher that's
a fully automatic rifle except it shoots
rockets and so you can juggle cars and
things like that so we'll give you
plenty of tools to be able to deal with
that chaos what's it like sort of I mean
it's been a good few years now since
crackdown 2 and in that time there have
been a lot of similar games I'm thinking
like Saints Row 4 I'm pretty sure had
blackhole gun or something very similar
what's it like sort of now being like on
the way back back guy it's yeah it's
it's been an incredibly exciting show
you know I've had a lot of fun hanging
out in the booths and watching people
play and you know I've already got we
came in and I had done you know a ten
minute playthrough and I had you know a
five star rating and I had my twenty six
thousand point and I've you know had a
person who's come back and played
multiple times they've almost beaten my
score now and so it's been a blast just
to watch people get to play and and
frankly seen people do crazy stuff on
the show floor that I wasn't expecting
either so weird feels like we're already
there
how are you really up the ante because
as a huge cracks I wanted to fan I'm
imagining it in my brain like every time
I play one of your games said how can
this get crazier because you always seem
to hit that ceiling of insanity so what
have you done to really push this
forward because without getting hands-on
yet I can't really imagine how crazy god
I mean a big part of that is that gang's
bite back system is the fact that you
can have all of these different elements
interacting to create experiences that
were completely unique to your
playthrough you know so if you've got a
boss battle and you end up you know
dragging that boss battle into another
area then triggering a retaliation then
again it just gives you this experience
that's completely your own and so for me
that's a big part of the game we've
always said like every playthrough is
different that's what we wanted and that
the gangs buy back is how we get there
uh this year's e3 press conference of
Microsoft not a lot of first party but
what they did have on show was this
incredible sort of mix of developer with
third third party relations right so
what was it like being sort of like at
the front and foremost and all eyes on
you guys and the pyro yeah yes it was
all sounds pretty cool um yeah we you
know you you're always in those moments
you're sit in the show and you're like I
can't wait for people to see this and it
starts with Terry Crews and people clap
through his first line so people didn't
even hear it like it's showing a game
for the first time and having a big
reveal like that it's it's always the
most it's one of most exhilarating parts
of making games so now you're you know
getting gearing up to release it's like
it's it's on the horizon now I mean the
reason a lot of people got the first
crackdown you it was like bundled with
Halo movie Turkey and you've obviously
got a lot of of Steve's in your back
catalogue why why now why with this xbox
1x do you think that's going to push you
over the over the horizon though you do
think you're going to be the ones to be
like this this game is the reason to buy
an xbox connects yes I think when you
see this in 4k with our explosions with
all that bombastic crazy action and are
living graphic novel style
I think it's it's amazing on Xbox one X
but also playing on xbox one s playing
on Xbox one playing on Windows 10 and it
was important for us also to have cross
play across those devices so just
because you've got a friend playing on a
different device doesn't mean you can't
play co-op together what's been the
biggest challenge in bringing crackdown
3 to ruins I guess I mean I think you
know crackdown has such a devoted
following even after you know the you
know it's been what 10 years since the
original or so and people it's still one
of these games that people talk about
they remember their stories and we knew
that it had to come back right and so
that the focus was on taking it back to
its roots but pushing it forward how do
we change it how do we add to it so it
feels like again you know every
playthrough is different and it's it
that's always the challenge with these
games is trying to bring these back and
you've got to make sure like okay this
has to feel like the original crack has
to feel like a love letter to fans of
the original and I think that we're in a
really good spot there since it's been
seven years since crackdown 2 now that's
kind of a lot of time to be away from
away from the spotlight now crackdown 3
is any hair you determine to remain in
the gaming space and say like crackdown
is now here to stay
we're not going anywhere for a while
we've got cool stuff to show you that is
absolutely my hope I mean obviously you
know we're focused on landing a super
high quality campaign experience and
then an incredibly and a game-changing
competitive multiplayer experience and
right now we're focused on that for
November 7th awesome
well Clinton thank you so much for
joining us so November 7th
remember 7 Xbox one Xbox 1s X and s PC
on the same day Windows 10 yep excellent
thank you so much for joining you for
having me
guys make sure you don't go anywhere in
just a few shots we'll be talking about
the crew - don't go anywhere